joining me today is dr. tino son and
dodgy tino is an economics researcher at
the Stockholm School of Economics Sweden
he's originally occurred from Iran who
moved to Sweden at the age of nine and
has written extensively about
immigration policy Tina welcome to the
show thank you I'm very excited to talk
to you because I have been harassing you
for about six months on email everyone
said I've mentioned on the show a couple
of times I want to talk to someone in
Sweden about immigration and everyone
kept saying he knows the guy to talk to
you've got to talk to him and finally we
have made this happen so I'm looking
forward to it yeah me too and I'm happy
you were patient and you know with you
since you want you to me I really want
to do it so I didn't say no I just
thought please now is not the time right
usually I just say no yeah well all
right let's get right to it because
there's there's a lot I want to talk to
you about and there and there's so much
misinformation generally about the
immigration situation all over Europe
but it seems like Sweden seems to be
like the epicenter of it so before we
dive into that though let's just talk
about your history a little bit
so you're occurred originally from Iran
and now you're in certain card your are
you're still occurred right you still
you're still ethnically occurred of
course and we've talked a bunch about
the Kurds here so just tell me a little
bit about your childhood growing up what
what sort of brought you from Iran to
Sweden etc yes so I my parents are
Kurdish but I was born in Tehran in the
capital which is the Persian area and
and Iran I try to simplify to Westerners
Kurds and Persians are both Iranian but
curves are not Persian just like Scots
and English are both British but the
Scots are not English mm-hm and that's
sort of like the Scots are the Kurds of
Europe right you want you know so
Mountaineers independent minded very
proud people and by grew up in Tehran
and in servin secular like many Iranians
so Iran you know as you know very well
and maybe not
every American realizes is a very
divided country because you're Americans
know about the Islamist and the regime
but Iran also has a very very large
group perhaps even the majority at this
point that are really western-oriented
secular people who are oppressed by the
Islamic movement and we did not we are
not refugees and I've always said that
from day one we did not have reasons for
a sigh let me never you know and the
reason we like we had it also I would
say better economically in Iran than we
in Sweden and that's not the reason we
moved is because because of freedom of
speech you want to live in a democracy
we didn't want to live in Islamic
Republic my mother had to cover herself
it's very oppressive it's sort of right
it's violates the mind to always being
have to abide by this and my father
didn't want to leave Iran because you
were sort of a patriot and he was hoping
that the Islamic Revolution would fall
with Islamic government but after
Ayatollah Khomeini died and all his
friends left or most of them you know
they were they he was Americanized u.s.
educated I think he went to Sacramento
and all his friends were like that and
you know me and my brother we sort of
grew up in the with the line that went
around us it was never intellectually
transition for me removed from Iran to
Sweden right I've read the same lid I've
read the Astrid Lindgren when I was in
Iran which is a Swedish author right
anyway but all his friends left but he
didn't he was a patriot he wanted to
stay and he was hoping that when Harini
died and the regime would fall or at
least moderate but it didn't happen so
then we go ahead
yeah then we moved to Sweden it was a
lot again - it was difficult me my
mother and brother younger brother one
year younger he was on site and but for
his book on marginal revolution today so
he's also an intellectual in his own
right and we moved to Sweden we live
there and I studied I grew up myself in
I lived 10 years on welfare grew up
single mother and I grew up in the surf
housing air projects
to the Stockholm School of Economics for
my master's degree and then I went to
University of Chicago then I came back
to Sweden it was different one year also
to my postdoc then I came back to Sweden
and now I'm a researcher here and let me
emphasize that I've never done research
on immigration and that's not my area
I've done public economics
entrepreneurship Nam doing historical
economics the emergence of work ethic
and how important that is for why
certain countries I had thrust why
different countries have been able to
have welfare states to at the larger
level at an to sustain it whereas it
doesn't work in other countries for
cultural reasons I would argue right
anyway that's my research and this
immigration debate is something that I
mean immigration is the sub category of
economics it's not a research field in
its own in the subject area and it's
part of labor and public forums and so
I've never done research in it because
I've said that I don't I don't
philosophically believe that you should
do research empirically at least on
topics that you care a lot about right
so far besides other people yeah okay so
let's pause there because you gave me a
lot so so first off just to be clear so
when I said I want to talk to someone
about immigration that is not
specifically what you do it's more about
economics but you're saying these things
are sort of combined I think more than
anything else people wanted me to talk
to you because they're saying to me that
you're one of the few people in Sweden
willing to at least talk about it so
it's in a way it's that you've been
funneled to this and you are an
immigrant yourself so we're going to get
into some of the specifics but you
certainly are not against immigration in
that you are a middle-eastern immigrant
to to Sweden sure I mean being against
immigration is likely if you are
debating how hard should taxes be are
you dumb it down to are you against
taxes right either you 100 percent tax
rate or zero percent taxes right that's
stupid the question is how much
immigration what type in your
immigration do we want right exactly so
just one other thing on your history
which I thought was interesting there so
you mentioned so you came from a Kurdish
family in Iran but your family
did they want Kurdistan to exist
separately from Iran it sounds like they
were certain even though they were
problems that they yeah so that's a very
very difficult question my answer
probably would know my father probably
most of his life didn't toward the end
of his life he did probably I think he
met he changed his views on that and
it's a difficult question because I
don't know I don't I don't know how much
you want to get into this but there are
Kurds largely in four countries
Turkey is the biggest one then followed
by Iran Iraq Syria now the relationship
between the Kurds in Iran is the one
that the Kurds are most closely
affiliated with the Persians
so the Kurds have to speak an ironic
language reigning language and the
movement to independence is the weakest
in Iran and it's as strong as the
historic in Iraq and then the other
three are two are now very strong as
well Turkey and there and Syria yeah
Iranian Kurds culturally feel closer to
a Persians then third Kurds would feel
three turks think the Iranian um had a
genocide against the Kurds you know the
Kurds probably although this is not
contested originates from the Medes who
are just sort of like it's just if you
go back 3,000 years difference the same
people and you know the Greek would
often refer to the Persian Empire as the
Medes so it's the famous line where were
you how old were you who are you my
friend what you do how old were you when
the meat came that's when the Persians
came right and for these reasons this
independence movement had been weakest
and I think even the Kurdish parties
most of them never demanded independence
they want self-rule and my father was
one of those people who was very per
side and he he believed strongly in the
Iranian ideas sort of rather than a
Kurdish I don't I believe in Kurdish
independence I'm a huge fan of Persian
culture I think that that's the one of
the world's top 10 high civilizations
and was a great influence on the Kurds
to be neighbors with the person of great
respect for them but if you ask my
primary role of Iranians or friend
advise Iranian czar Patriots and most
many Iranians are even Patriots before
there is Muslims
but I personally believe Kurtz should
have an independence and my argument and
we should be allies with Iran mm-hmm and
my argument is that if and not if not
else the Islamic Republic has deleted
mised them and the Kurds would never do
this
like if the Persians would have been
more liberal minded and reasonable maybe
but then the person sundar Zuri they
went to these radicalism and they ruined
Iran which was in 1960 and 1970 after
Japan Iran has the highest growth rate
per capita in the world Wow right yeah
so it's partially oil but not entirely
all these before the rise in oil prices
it's a very highly educated country it
has a tradition to three thousand years
of science and education everything like
that and even a you know Iran had a very
Constitution in the early 20th century
that was more liberal than many European
countries unfortunately they reactionary
forces were stronger and it could didn't
stick it was close yeah and
unfortunately to my my view on that
issue is that the Kurd occurs in
whatever historical relations we have I
don't aren't sure I shouldn't have to
live under Islamic Republic's and the
course would never themselves do this
this is what they did so then that's the
root cause for divorce let's say right
so okay so we can go down that rabbit
hole for the next five hours if we want
but I just wanted to ask you that
because we've talked a bit about the
Kurds and I know it's so complex because
of being split with all these countries
and all that okay so you moved to Sweden
when you're nine years old you mentioned
you were on welfare for ten years with a
single mother so that really gets to the
heart I think of what's happening in
Sweden now Sweden has incredibly good
social services right and that's why all
these immigrants want to come there can
you tell me a little bit about that oh
sure
so Sweden and the others kind of eight
countries have they're spending as a
share social spending as a share of the
economy is among the highest in the
world together with France these are the
highest countries and Sweden has become
less generous in recent years it's
not quite the Utopia that Bernie Sanders
perk Paul Krugman images and for Krugman
specifically says that his ideal Society
through the 1980
not student today and part of course
perhaps not acknowledge this place
because integration you just can't
afford but anyway that's that's an
important distinction though because
you're taking a homogeneous society
bringing in all these people giving them
a lot it worked at that point nineteen
eighty or whatever it was and now you're
seeing the change so we shouldn't gloss
over that no it should I'm gonna get to
it yeah I'm just going to go to generous
it is but here it's not the only cause I
mean the public shouldn't it's also
reasons having to do with the structural
change pressing the economy that in
nineteen eighty you had more of a big
corporations you know could you could
have an innovation economy based around
big corporations and those Sweden always
had those and that was carried Sweden
was as Milton Friedman pointed out when
you're in the street in 1958 I believe
it is always been is capitalist society
it's a capitalist society with a lot of
free enterprise and very very generous
regulation on business very free market
but very high taxes and redistribute so
that's the key anyway it's not a
socialist country at all and American
libertarians or conservatives should
never say that because that's going to
make people falsely attributed to serve
sure that the Train never had central
planning business was private business
was always private so that's that's a
really interesting distinction because I
think people think of it as oh this
Bernie wants to turn America into Sweden
and Sweden is working and there's a
socialist component but what you're
saying is it's really capitalists and
the the businesses are free to do what
they want but people are taxed very high
and that's how you deal with the social
safety net and that's a real distinction
there yes that's completely right and
Bernie wants to make the u.s. Sweden and
Mello of suits politicians want to make
sure they're into Mexico and I get a
chart yeah anyway so for example I think
if you are a small family and you don't
work the Swedish government is going to
give you something equivalent to two
thousand
dollars a month well in ralpher that's
high you have free health care free
college free schooling bus three school
you have the u.s. too but still and free
daycare almost well if you're poor it's
free if you're not poor it's almost free
all these things are taxed financed and
of course this means that the typical
labourer will tax 55 an average percent
of their income in total including sales
tax on a rich person maybe even 70% well
to fund this but it's still to this day
97% of Swedes support social safety net
it's very strong popular support and
however and it's this attracts
immigrants it's not the only thing that
attracts the immigrants by the way
immigrants would come I should say even
if this is an exist just because Sweden
is wealthy because as long as you have
wages earning in India or Africa parts
of the Middle East when you people earn
a thousand dollars a year something like
that even if coming and begging in
Sweden is maybe better better than that
right but of course this attracts and
what's happened is that this system
worked when a eighty-five to ninety
percent of working-age adults work
that's also key of Sweden more in the
u.s. mm-hmm
however among the non European
immigrants half of them don't work in H
don't work and you could fund the
Swedish welfare state when eighty-five
percent work full participation
you can't fund it if this share the
population that first of all doesn't
work and if they work they typically
earn 20% less because they're more more
in low skilled labour and so on in and
is traditionally the Social Democrats in
student Norway Denmark they they realize
they articulated this they said look we
can have a welfare state for CEM as they
call it we can have a fall camp for
eight million Swedes
we can afford that we can't afford it
for a billion or five billion poor
people right and they that therefore
this kind of a very very restrictive
immigration I was and I was accepted but
what happened later on is that this
became associated with racism and there
is an ID among many Swiss both the
libertarian sort of the
bleeding-heart libertarians and the
socialist cultural socialist world I'd
is racist to say our exclude somebody
because they happen not to be born in
Sweden and this is a conflict that's
tearing a country apart yeah and we see
this all over Europe right now and we're
seeing the beginnings of it in America
and that's why I've been talking about
this issue because I see this this
conversation not being have we're not
having it in any sort of effective way
here and I see all these people in
Europe and why people wanted me to talk
to you and talk about Sweden because you
guys are dealing with this right now
so when did that when did that creeping
idea of political correctness when did
that really start for you guys that's a
very difficult question look a lot of
people would say 1968 is when this was
exploded but then it took a huge lag
before it transformed into policy and
mmm perhaps you could 1968 there was a
because of Vietnam by the way so the the
American in my opinion excessive foreign
policy indirectly caused this and it
destroyed a lot of goodwill that existed
toward the US and toward the right for
no end anyway so what happened is that
this caused huge student movement you're
the rise of communism
I love the intellectual elite in Europe
in particularly in these North European
countries and France became Marxist the
various degrees they were not usually
pro-soviet because that was also
considered a mean country but they you
know in all the street journalists today
are either or either or still openly
Marxist Leninist or they used to when
they were young I don't talk about it
mmm-hmm and then this gradually add
there is what also night shift Sweden
used to have a strong student as well it
got a tear in country which I mean I
appreciate their they have a glare
Italian knowns you know Ronald Reagan
said this too that it really quality is
being equal in the eyes of each other
it's a cultural thing it's not just
about economics obviously if you have
too much economic inequality that's
going to destroy social inequality too
but but the core of it is not money it's
right it's sort of having respect for
each other and
not to humiliate people status hierarchy
and things like that this was a very
small as you mentioned homogeneous
society small nobility Northern Europe
Scandinavia was the only part of Europe
that never had serfdom that if peasants
were always free
these cultural traits remained and then
they had a strong labor movement but not
that much polarization it's not the
Soviet Union when they're trying to kill
each other right right and there was a
consensus in Jewish society so there was
a consensus to build for a welfare state
the word fall came it was originally
articulated by the right-wing in fact
not very left yeah and there were at
then the Social Democrats the centrist
elements were anti-marxist those were
Union people basically unions who wanted
this welfare state by the enlighten
distri see that's a big different bio
between shooting at us in the US you're
pro freedom from marcus you don't like
business suites love business right they
love big business but they don't
necessarily like capitalism brainy way
they these people had a moderate
pragmatic views they were a restricted
immigration and to this day these
hardcore sort of old-school social
democrats they're against this there are
my readers to a large extent are these
people the so it's quite partisan it
doesn't see that these old light right
and left issues have shifted because the
dimension has shifted what happened is
you had the cultural left ascendance
these were usually not working-class
people at order bourgeoisie or
upper-class
so rare champagne left yeah they did not
care that much about working-class
issues that's the the workers of
unwashed masses anyway they have
reactionary views you know they like to
drink this al bundy does not appeal to
them their issues were more a parked
post marxist issues of gender
multiculturalism great racial issues
serve at post colonialism and a lot of
it important because we didn't soon at
the time did not have a colonial
heritage it did not have really any
racial diversity right they would you
follow the debate in the u.s. at large
down
Cantus and they mimic those ideas so
that that's really interesting you guys
had a homogeneous society basically
obviously there was some immigration but
then sort of these bougie what now I
refer to and what we've been saying in
the stays light is this regressive left
ideology came in and they started
importing it was as if they were
importing an idea of a problem more than
the problem itself I mean that's that's
really fascinating that is true and to
this day and they use American lingo in
ways that make no sense but for example
they of course the series are not that
good at innovating these post-feminist
but you know the post Marxist ideas post
structures but they really good at
importing it and okay well it wasn't me
I'm absorbing it for example they use
the word race to fight that's you know
you have to go deep into post-colonial
studies Department refer in the US but
they used all the way your race to fight
means if you're let's say if I'm not
occurred but I am Kurt because you think
I'm a card you have ratified me minority
right that's one day left they usually
use the word Uncle Tom and I talk often
tell them the Kurds were not brought to
Sweden as slaves I don't know if you
identify as a sweet as your slave owners
but I don't
so saying Uncle Tom really doesn't make
sense when you don't have slavery right
and they use a lot of American without
translating it let you just say the
American word in English without
reflecting in either it's like two
twelve two legs that four legs good sort
of sort of thing right and anyway spent
an element of Toledo it's just not that
the leftism its sweets are very
sheltered they're very kind tolerant
sort of damaged by peace and affluence
and they had guilt they had guilt
watching on television that they were
affluent annual wars all over the world
and they start to bring refugees
initially few and initially was always
believed maybe as the u.s. who are you
making a fuss it's just five thousand
people it's just ten thousand people and
I've got okay but what happens if it's
ten thousand a year
and then each person has one or two
family reunification now you do it for
four years then you end up where you end
up right and anyway and they did that
not really there was never like an idea
of course sake let's make this country
multi-ethnic we don't like this
virginity and to this day can you stay
if you tell the Swedish leftist
immigration policy is gonna cost you
them ethnics wish to become the minority
they will scream and yell and say that's
not true on you and that's your Hitler
your whatever is not okay no yeah it's
very funny they just you know it's just
like crime stop they just shut up
thinking anyway so it started in the 80s
is when a non-european immigration
started so if you go back to World War
two before war to one percent were
immigrants more rounding it from other
Western European countries as late as
nineteen ninety-three percent were
non-western immigrants now maybe total
twenty three percent at this point of
foreign origin but that's an incredible
difference well although still about
maybe ten percentage points our Western
European or European and 13 percentage
points maybe are a non rest but but West
Region has the has and has had both the
highest rates of refugees per capita in
the West the some years you will have
hungry or Malta superseded by that
they're not giving them asylum that
doesn't count this is just transit
countries right moreover when a number I
usually tell sweets is that Sweden has
long surpassed the u.s. record as
immigration net immigration at the share
the population in the u.s. record is
around 1880 during the translation
variation we're taking far more than
that per year and of course in absolute
numbers it's a hundred and sixty
thousand thousand six three thousand
last year well the absolute numbers sure
that's less than Germany although that's
the only country doesn't want takes more
in straight in his Germany right and
there's plenty of problems right now
yeah it's you guys ten million people
they have eighteen eighty two million
people you have to
the population of shrewder right let me
give another number i like susan has 1.9
percent of the european union population
last year 40 percent of unaccompanied
minors now that this is extreme cut this
is an extreme country by the way I
should really emphasize this this has
stopped the Swedish government as the
last year says there is no limit if a
few years a few months into the asylum
crisis they say we are not going to put
barbed wire around Sweden there rambling
in the parliament about fascism and out
shoo it's a few days before they've
closed the borders the migration
Minister says if we close the borders
that could create a chain reaction that
destabilizes the Balkan you know they
have also these delusional ideas of how
important they are then they do it then
they have they cut a refugee flow since
then since they closed the border by 95
percent unaccounted miners by 99 percent
so now Sudan is at this moment if they
continue this we don't know because
there again there are voices on the left
say well a crisis averted let's open the
borders again but if they continue this
it could actually be averted so you know
it's no longer open borders in Sweden
right so ok so when it when it was open
borders did that mean that anyone who
showed up at the border could just a
walk across and be immediately get
asylum get these social services and
baseline it's become a citizen you asked
your questions yeah I could walk across
yes ok they could get social welfare yes
they could not become a stay here so let
me explain something that I think is
very important to understand about your
energy crisis both for Americans and
Europeans it's really very simple what
you have to understand is the way
Europeans regular an American regulate
refugee Asylum is a refugee that sets
foot on your border has the right by the
Geneva Convention to apply for asylum
and if they have grounds for asylum for
example war basically you have to give
them asylum ok but they have no right no
right on the moment they set foot across
the border and they need a visa to enter
a country and these countries do not
give to this day Germany will not
visa merkel does not give visas to
syrians in syria they have to penetrate
the border okay and historically you had
border crossings you have to pay you
know you have to pay smugglers somehow
trick yourself in then you go apply for
asylum if you have ground for asylum you
can stay of course if you just go from
Gambia they probably will not let you
stay unless you find a loophole right
okay what happen is that this country
has very strict border controls it's
like a tanker in students case you have
like you have to cross Denmark Germany
Austria Hungary Greece Turkey yeah few
people could do that so you could have
very generous grounds for giving asylum
like giving it to somebody like me who
didn't have the reason right really
logically to get but they're very few
could make it then they'd with the
European Union and Shanghai and a decent
assembled these border controls at the
maternal border and the outsourced to
Greece and Turkey then last year this
broke down because the Greeks stopped
enforcing it the countries in the
Central Europe start enforcing it in
Mora controls they could have chosen to
do it but it chose not to and the Turks
probably Aragon let them true or that's
not important to get you to that detail
for the first time in human history
there was a land route between Sweden
and the Middle East right so you could
sit on a bus basically simplifying it
from Afghanistan or Tehran where most
Afghans by the way came from from Iran
not from Afghanistan our Iraq Syria and
you take a bus to come to Sudan in your
private island once this happened it
just kept snowballing until these
countries one by one closed the border
back then it stopped and all this time
obfuscating and using lies and
misdirection to not make people
understand why this has happened
see that's the case people understood
you could have always taught the
instrument the the government about the
right on the left and the Immigration
Department they would officially go on
TV and say international law prohibits
us to close the borders not saying that
you couldn't push border controls it'll
prevent us from doing that and that
would close the borders are not telling
you that because you're dumb voters we
don't want
all these details right so that's that
gets to the heart of why I've been
talking about this that it seems to me
no one's having an honest discussion
about it no one's having an honest
discussion over what the system in any
of these given countries as you're
saying what the system can tolerate what
the system can do Germany let in
something like 1.3 million people
obviously I don't think Merkel was
intending some evil plan to have
immigrants take over the country well
you have willful ignorance so then
there's a lot of people with willful
ignorance and then there is these sort
of these leftists that as I keep saying
you know the road to hell is paved with
good intentions they have this they
think they're doing something good and
then at the same time they're destroying
the very systems that allow them to live
the way they want to live that's true
everything you say is true and this is a
lot of is about is about misdirected
altruism and and oxytocin poisoning and
so on but I do believe there is this
there's a darker side to these stories
well let me try to articulate it yeah I
think this comparative compassion it's
not true compassion for sure because I
say I actually I always said you the
question is not should we help the
refugees is how do we help the most
effectively and my suggestion is for
every dollar or kroner we cut on refute
taking refugees in Sweden we give to to
the UN program so I want to double how
much we spend on this but doing it in a
way that actually saves it solves the
problem at the micro level not just
symbolically you take a few thousand
people most many of whom don't need the
help and are economic refugees sort of
using this you know not not to moralize
right I understand they're doing it but
they don't would not die too close
approximation nobody with a student did
not save one life wait why do people do
this I think is the mechanism the
mechanism is there try to upend other
people in their own societies I want to
show them I'm more altruistic than you
are then therefore I'm a better person
and they bully each other that's where
you're getting a lot of hate coming out
from them you're not seeing a lot of
love and that includes Merkel by the way
you know they're using like this kind of
very very
false raises accusation lying constantly
good people don't need to lie yeah
what'd they do this brown smearing they
try to use insinuation you know
everybody that sees a parallel between
Afghans who live in Tehran and decide
they want to have higher quality of life
in student and the Holocaust
none person is dishonest because anyway
logical person who understand that is
not the parallel but the other example
is Alan Kurdi was a three-year-old child
who died right at these pictures yeah
what called let's look at this story so
there's a child who grew up in Turkey
had protection in Turkey and their
family openly say they moved to the West
to have better economic conditions that
openly say that and they did not drown
or die running away from Syria they
drowned moving from Turkey to Greece and
by the way about three four five
thousand fifteen hundred more people
have drowned since that three hundred
more children by the way mm-hmm and
people reacted by not asking so why this
child died
the answer is because the European
libertarians and the European left they
incentivize that choice family to take a
risk to cross the Mediterranean to get
higher quality of life they that's why
they the trial die okay and these they
create that lottery when they say if you
cross the Mediterranean you make it you
can have a higher quality of life but
you have a 0.3 probability of dying I'm
not going to give you a visa so you can
safely fly here I grant you that right
there you call too many of you but I'll
let Ali incentivize a system where more
and more people drown - in 2010 20
people drowned in the Mediterranean rice
here four to four thousand people
drowned in Mediterranean it's nine
eleven one nine eleven a year yeah and
then when you when you couple you need
to take a country like Greece which has
massive economic problems right now you
can understand why you know you see
these videos every few weeks now of
migrants coming in boats and then you
have the Greek Navy trying they're
either shooting at the boats or they're
trying to get them away and it's like
you don't want those people to die
and then at the same time the Greek
system is struggling to stand on its own
so it's just so complaining salt
Australian salted if you come in this
way there is no way you asylum end of
story then you remove the incentive then
we discuss how you can help them and
let's all be adults and understand there
is no war in Turkey at least maybe there
is a smaller scale war far apart has
nothing to do with this with the Kurdish
issue but but in these areas for there
is no war nobody is crossing the
Mediterranean is running from grenades
ok they're already in safety the
question is then how do you deal with
this and let's look at some of these
numbers
it's like Swedish spending something
like only on initial taking refugees 10
million 10 billion dollars here well the
entire UN budget for all the refugees
that actually argue that they're gay
it's something like 5 billion
so certainly spending twice as much on
0.3% of the refugees then the UN has Wow
very signs of these guys like I talked
about the 1 percent 9 percent that's the
bigger disparity right that's a much
bigger disparity and by the way the 0.3
percent probably you're not saving their
life what you're doing is right and live
in Turkey or rather than live in Iran or
other other countries or they're not
really have war there are something like
Iraq we even Iraq it's not full-scale
war right I'm living there they live in
Western Europe that's what's doing
you're not saving their lives you know
in both Sweden and Finland all of the
refugees or have left and they say we
are displaced it takes too long we are
this you know we it's not what we
expected the quality of life turned off
but that tells you something right
somebody you know voluntarily goes back
because they just say I'm not having a
quality of living what that person
probably was not desperately running for
their life like people imagine and then
the question because this to my you say
are these good intentions I would said
some deep level they're not this isn't
this is like it you want to pretend to
do good do do well and maybe you
convince yourself but deep down what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
raise your own status and sort of push
your own ideology and ideas on
your surrounding otherwise you would
have a rational debate yeah you
generally want to help people why are
your feeling to discuss it rationally
well that's what people on the Left seem
to be doing all the time now we're
calling it virtue signaling that they
want you to think that they're so
virtuous so we can help everybody I was
on a radio show with a guy and he was
telling me how he would be for everybody
can come to America all the time and all
I said basically was well you know I
just would like to know at the border
that were vetting people properly in
blah blah blah and he was jumping all
over me as if that made me racist and
what I was trying to do is exactly what
you said which is let's have an honest
discussion about this I understand that
my great-grandparents were immigrants so
I would always err on the side of
immigrants but we have to make sure our
system works
well let me say only what that's though
if your great-great grandparents were
immigrants let me change the frame and
the American America took them don't you
have an even greater obligation to this
country that's somebody who it was
better right so it's just you can look
at it either way but yeah yeah yeah you
worry about that you know there is a
quote probably there is no evidence
Churchill said but it's a great quote
anyway which is the fascist of the
future will appear as anti fascist
uh-huh that's what happened and and
there is a great deal of anger and
intolerance in this ideology but I would
buy a wave one thing I don't agree what
you say is that the left that's
debatable I think that or the fact I
defined it I think you've seen the same
thing with the libertarians in both the
US and in Europe the libertarian right
in here at least I know to solve them in
you the Iran crowd there are even more
nuts than the Marxist yeah it's funny I
just two weeks ago I had the the
president of the Iran Institute and
unfortunately we didn't get much into
immigration but our libertarian movement
here is not it's very fractured it's
fractured I know I know you have you
have a big variety fracture there and
you have the sort of Patriot
libertarians paleo libertarian I know
yeah but still you know they've done a
lot of damage with these unscientific
ideas that their immigration is always
good it can never be bad for economy and
you cannot do
is interesting is it sort of proto
Marx's ideas people do not have the more
right not to have immigration even if
they hurt as long as you raise the
global utility that's a very common idea
among the libertarian economists wait a
second that's a Marxist idea that if I
can prove that redistribution likes
everybody me more better after it hurts
you I have the right to take your goods
it's very interesting that they have and
what they do by race they cheat they try
to pretend that their ideas are coherent
by distorting reality like claiming that
immigration is always good for economy
which is not true
you're never being true or claiming that
it's not going to lead to social problem
it doesn't raise crime that's what they
that's how they get around to these
dilemmas they just lie about it